Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Wir blicken mal wieder auf die Premier League, da hat sich schon wieder so einiges getan. Und wir wollen das alles erläutern mit Marco Hagemann, der unter anderem auf der Zone genau zu dieser Premier League zu hören ist. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Marco, freut mich sehr, dich mal hier begrüßen zu dürfen. Hi! Sehr schön. Wir wollen über die Premier League sprechen. Und wir müssen allerdings mit einem Thema anfangen, was das Ganze so ein bisschen überlagert hat in den letzten Tagen. Nämlich der Tod von Emiliano Salah, der von Nord zu Cardiff City gewechselt ist. Und jetzt haben wir die Gewissheit, er ist auf dem Rückweg nach Cardiff, nachdem er sich von seinen Teamkollegen verabschiedet hatte, ums Leben gekommen. Wie ist deine Einschätzung? Was hat das in der Premier League ausgelöst? Wie waren da die Reaktionen drauf?
Naja, das muss man natürlich mit Bestützung aufnehmen. Und so war es ja auch in England und ich glaube auch über den Tellerrand hinaus, sprich auch in ganz Europa. Also das ist ja an jedem jetzt nicht gerade spurlos vorbeigekommen und jeder hat das mitbekommen. Und dementsprechend ist die Bestützung sehr groß und wir haben ja auch ein Jahr mit zwei großen Tragödien, gerade auch was, wenn wir uns über die Premier League unterhalten, leider miterleben müssen. Den Hubschrauberabsturz bei Ballester City, der war ja auch schon sehr, sehr tragisch und jetzt diese Geschichte, ja, das zeigt da immer wieder und viele sagen das ja auch, dass da der Fußball natürlich komplett in den Hintergrund rückt und vor solchen Dingen sind wir eben nicht befreit und gerade auch nicht im Sport. Leider passiert sowas auf der Welt tagtäglich. Die Frage ist immer, was wir immer so mitbekommen haben und dass es natürlich jetzt so ausgegangen ist, das ist natürlich schon heftig und ja, wir haben es ja schon auch in der Liga gesehen mit Schweigeminuten und so. Natürlich auch vollkommen richtig und alle nebenteil daran. Auch sogar im Tennis. Ich habe glaube ich jetzt heute oder gestern von Juan Martin del Porto auch was gelesen. Also das geht nicht an allen, wenn die Spur ist vorbei.
Genau, du hast es ja auch schon richtig eingeordnet. Das sind halt die Fälle, die wir mitbekommen. Tragöden gibt es jeden Tag und zählige. Und dennoch ging auch noch eine Nebendebatte dazu los, das fand ich relativ bemerkenswert, nämlich dass Nantes dennoch davon ausgeht, die Transfersumme von Cardis City erhalten zu werden. Das sind 15 Millionen Pfund und die erste Rechnung über die erste Rate hatten sie schon gestellt. Hat das denn ein Echo hervorgerufen in der Premier League? Mich hat es ein bisschen überrascht.
Tja, das ist ja so hart, wie es dann ist und so wahnsinnig, wie es sich dann auch anhört, dass das Leben natürlich dann auch weitergeht. Ich hoffe einfach mal, dass sich beide Vereine dann in irgendeiner Art und Weise auch einig werden, dass man vielleicht auch einen Weg findet, der für beide Seiten vernünftig dann auch ausgeht. Natürlich, wenn ein Verein auf Millionen pocht, das hat so einen faden Beigeschmack und ist eigentlich auch schon – naja, also wenn du das so als Außenstehender miterlebst, dann ist es schon sehr, sehr makaber, sich über Millionen Transfersumme zu unterhalten, über einen Spieler, der ums Leben gekommen ist. Da findet man ja gar keine Worte für. Auf der anderen Seite sieht man halt, wie brutal manchmal dieses Geschäft dann auch ist. Und ich würde mal fast sagen, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes geht man schon fast über Leichen. Und das ist, ich finde, schon fast widerwärtig, dort jetzt noch auf Geld zu pochen, für einen Spieler, den es einfach mit einem Flugzeugabstoß erwischt hat und der nicht mal unter uns walt. Das ist auch für die Familie denke ich mal überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar. Also da sollte Nons vielleicht auch mal einen Schritt zurückgehen und zu sagen, also bitte, das regeln wir natürlich jetzt auf einen ganz anderen Wege. Und dass das eh schon an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen ist, dass man so überhaupt handelt. Dafür fehlen mir komplett die Worte, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Und ich hoffe, dass es vielen so geht und dass die Empathie, die Sensibilität bei vielen Geschäftsleuten auch dann hoffentlich so weit ausgereift ist, dass man sich über diesen Vorgang auch wirklich einfach mal beschwerden, dass man das öffentlich auch ankreidet. Denn das ist glaube ich der einzig richtige Weg.
Ja, gut. Ich meine vielleicht auch eine Frage der Art und Weise, wie man das Ganze kommuniziert. Wer weiß, was dahinter steht. Kann ja sein, dass das versicherungstechnische Gründe hat, dass man die Rechnung stellen muss. Cardis City hat auch gesagt, sie wollen erst mal jetzt abwarten, bis man Gewissheit hat und dann erst mal klären, waren sie jetzt eigentlich versichert gegen diesen Verlust. Das ist ja noch zu kleines Wort. Wir alle wissen, wie es gemeint ist. Also wer weiß, was es da für Hintergründe gab. Vielleicht, also Nort hat das ja definitiv auch getroffen. Aber es ist eben so eine bittersüße Fußnote. Nein, eigentlich nur bitter. Nichts Süßes steckt da mit drin und ich fand das bemerkenswert. Eben auch die Art und Weise, wie das rauskam. Da hätte Nort sich vielleicht ein bisschen anders behalten.
Also das musst du dann tatsächlich hinter den Vorhängen diskutieren. Ich verstehe auch den ganzen Ansatz. Also du hast ja auch vorkommen recht, dass dich da versehungstechnische Dinge logischerweise abspielen. Das ist im Privatleben ja genauso oder bei ganz normalen Familien. Wenn dort einer ums Leben kommt, durch Flugzeugabstürze etc. Natürlich werden dann auf Versicherungen eingeschaltet, ist ja gar keine Frage. Nur das musst du einfach in den eigenen vier Wänden letztendlich auch dann so hinbekommen, dass es keiner mitkriegt. Dass es jetzt so in die Öffentlichkeit gekommen ist und wie es an die Öffentlichkeit gekommen ist. Und was man dann letztendlich auch daraus macht. Das darf in diesem Falle überhaupt nicht passieren, weil dann ist es tatsächlich einfach makaber, wenn man sich nur diesen Fakt letztendlich auch ansieht.
Okay, und damit versuchen wir dann mal aber dann doch den Bogen zum Sportlichen zu spannen, denn auch da hat sich ja einiges getan in der Premier League. Wir haben einen neuen alten Tabellenanführer, nämlich Manchester City. Die haben allerdings auch ein Spiel mehr, sind jetzt punktgleich mit Liverpool. Und wir erinnern uns noch, vor wenigen Tagen sah es so aus, als könnte Liverpool auf sieben Punkte Abstand davon ziehen. Was hat denn City gerade, dass Liverpool abgeht?
Wie es mal so im Sport ist, und Jürgen Klopp hat das, ich glaube, während der Saison auch schon das Öfteren mal gesagt, ein kleines Tief bei einem Verein, sprich Liverpool, und der andere Verein punktet dann doch konstant. Und wenn du, wie Liverpool, jetzt zweimal nacheinander Unentschieden spielst und dein größter Konkurrent gewinnt, haltest und Punkte dreifach, dann ist so ein Unentschieden dann einfach schon fast eine Niederlage. Und dann reduziert sich ganz schnell mal ein Vorsprung dahin, dass du derzeit tatsächlich punktgleich mit Manchester City da oben stehst und aufgrund des schlechteren Torverhältnisses im Moment Platz zwei inne hast. Und plötzlich bist du dann doch, auch wenn du ein Spiel weniger hast und ausgetragen hast, aktuell in einer Jägerrolle. So muss man es tatsächlich auch mal formulieren. Das passiert nun mal. Und wir sehen das auch bei Tottenham. Entweder gewinnen sie, und das tun sie in den meisten Fällen, oder sie verlieren halt in dieser Saison schon sechs Mal in dieser Spielzeit. Aber sie spielen nicht unentschieden und sammeln natürlich durch ihre vielen Siege dreifach Punkte und sind dann eben auch nicht ganz so weit weg. Das passiert, ich glaube, dass Liverpool eben genau dieses kleine Tief – wir reden ja wirklich von einem Niveau, was ja immer noch unfassbar gut ist – aber das kann natürlich mal passieren in so einer langen Saison, dass dann Spieler, die sehr viel gespielt haben – ich habe Liverpool zuletzt bei Western United kommentiert und habe mir die Zahlen auch noch mal ganz genau angeguckt – und wenn du dann Spieler hast, die da heißen Van Dijk oder die da heißen, gerade die da vorne Salah, Femino, Mané, die kaum eine Pause bekommen haben in dieser Saison, also ganz, ganz wenig Rotationen, die fast permanent in der Startelf stehen, dass die auch mal eine kleine Leistungsstelle haben oder beziehungsweise mal ein kleines Formloch und vielleicht nicht so performen, wie man sich vorstellt, dann kann sich so ein Vorsprung ganz schnell mal komplett aufheben. Ich bin jetzt weit davon entfernt, erstmal zu sagen, Liverpool ist schon nervös geworden und der Druck ist so groß, wie es dann immer solche Platitüten gibt. Dafür, finde ich, ist man viel zu weit weg. Natürlich macht das irgendwas mal im Kopf. Die Spieler sind ja nicht alle blöd und kriegen das ja auch mit. Welche historische Möglichkeit sie haben, in der Liga die Meisterschaft zu gewinnen, das ist vollkommen richtig. Aber zum jetzigen Stand, wir schreiben Anfang Februar, glaube ich, bei weitem nicht, dass die Nervosität so groß sein könnte, wie sie vielleicht von einigen versucht wird, reinzutragen.
Man hat sowohl gegen Leicester als auch gegen West Ham 1-1 gespielt und vorher gegen Crystal Palace dramatisch mal wieder Liverpool-style zu Hause 4-3 gewonnen. Was aufgefallen ist, was auffällig war in den beiden Spielen gegen Leicester und West Ham, war ja vor allem, dass Liverpool viel weniger Torchancen kreiert hat, vor allem hochklassige Torchancen als in den Spielen zuvor. Würdest du das dann eben auf diese Mehrfachbelastung und auf die physische und psychische Frische oder eben dann fehlende Frische auch zurückführen? Oder hat es vielleicht auch mit den Gegnern zu tun, dass die Liverpool anders begegnen?
Ja klar, also Gegner gehört immer mit dazu. Aber ja, das ist sicherlich auch ein Teilaspekt. Ich habe das im Kommentar gegen West Ham auch gesagt, wenn du eben dich nicht nur auf die Abhängigkeit verlassen kannst, die Salah, Manet, Femino bringen, dann fehlt mir – ich habe das auch schon während der Saison mal gesagt – da fehlt mir so eine wirklich gefährliche Unterstützung, gerade bei Liverpool, aus dem Mittelfeld heraus. Ich glaube, defensiv haben sie jetzt auch ein paar gefangen, aber du kannst ja auch nicht davon ausgehen, dass sie jedes Spiel zu Null spielen. Das passiert dann eben. Aber ich meine, bei West Ham sind sie auch in Führung gegangen. Aber so die Unterstützung heraus, die vielleicht ein Oxlade Chamberlain bringen könnte – leider ist er ja schon sehr, sehr lange verletzt – Shakiri hat das mal punktuell gebracht, hat aber auch so eine kleine Delle im Moment. Aber ein Wijnaldum, ein Henderson, ein Milner, wenn er dann mal im Mittelfeld wieder spielen kann, ein Fabinho, ein Navigator – da kommen halt zu wenig Tore. Das ist, glaube ich, ein ganz, ganz entscheidender Punkt, warum du auch dann mal spiele, wenn die vorne die drei Mal nicht treffen sollen und nicht in der Regelmäßigkeit treffen sollten, die dann eben auch fehlen. Dann brauchst du vielleicht auch mal einen Mittelfeldspieler dahinter, der auch mal für sechs, sieben, acht Tore in einer Saison gut ist. Da hat, glaube ich, Manchester City noch einen positiveren Ansatz, positivere Optionen, das vielleicht ein bisschen wegzumachen und haben nicht die pure Abhängigkeit auf vielleicht ein, zwei Spieler. Aber es gibt viele Möglichkeiten. Nochmal, ich möchte das gar nicht alles so permanent negativ sehen, weil es jetzt gerade eine Phase ist, die im Sport dazugehört. Die Saison ist noch lang, also wir haben ja nicht nur noch zwei Spieltage, sondern wir haben noch ein paar mehr Spieltage zu absolvieren und man kann sich ganz schnell aus einem Loch wieder auch befreien. Liverpool hat vor dem Champions-League-Spiel gegen die Bayern jetzt noch mal Pause, also nach Bornwith, zehn Tage. Da kannst du dich sehr schnell auch regenerieren, das ist ja fast wie ein kleiner Urlaub letztendlich. Und nochmal an Dingen pfeilen und deine Form wieder so ein bisschen zurückgewinnen. Also alles weniger dramatisch, obwohl man natürlich aufpassen muss, ist ja gar keine Frage, als vielleicht hier und da skizziert.
Und auf der anderen Seite über City haben wir jetzt fast noch gar nicht gesprochen. Die haben gegen Newcastle dieses Spiel mit 1 zu 2 verloren, wo eigentlich auch Newcastle nicht so wirklich die Chancen für zwei Tore hatte und dann aber sehr, sehr überzeugende Spiele abgeliefert. Gegen Arsenal mit 3 zu 1 gewonnen, in Everton mit 2 zu 0 gewonnen, jetzt wartet Chelsea auf City. Was läuft denn bei City gerade, was vielleicht in den vergangenen Wochen nicht immer zu sehen war?
Sie haben ja so einen kleinen Hänger gehabt, da um Weihnachten herum mit Leicester City, mit Crystal Palace. Diese Niederlage, Newcastle, die kann halt mal passieren. Wir reden ja immer noch über einen Sport, der auch sehr davon abhängt, wie deine Tagesform ist. Das kann ja passieren. Also, das sind ja alles keine Maschinen und auf Knopfdruck funktionieren sie. Das kann passieren. Dieses Spiel kann auch in eine völlig andere Richtung gehen und gerade nach 24 Sekunden mit dem Führungstreffer, dann gewinnst du vielleicht auch mal richtig dreckig mit 1 zu 0 da oder auch ruht es vielleicht an einen Punkt. Aber vielleicht hast du nochmal die Sinne geschärft und Pep Guardiola hat dann auch ein bisschen die Möglichkeit auch noch ein bisschen zu rotieren, was er auch wieder getan hat. Spieler wie Kevin de Bruyne, lange verletzt gewesen. Ich hatte den Eindruck zuletzt in den letzten zwei, drei Spielen schon, dass er immer stärker wird, dass er wieder seine Dynamik auch findet. Ich glaube, dass man von ihm auch noch ein bisschen mehr erwarten kann und auch sehen wird in den kommenden Wochen. Wir sprachen über Torgefahr aus dem Mittelfeld heraus. Er ist ja auch ein Vorlagengeber und kann ihm selbst Tore schießen. Er hat die Sinne geschärft und sie haben dann relativ überzeugend die nächsten beiden Partien auch gewonnen. Vielleicht haben sie ihr Loch oder ihre Fehler jetzt überwunden, wenn wir sehen. Wir können auch nicht in die Glaskugel gucken. Das ist ein ganz schmaler Grad, glaube ich, wie so ein Spiel verläuft, was für eine Tagesform du hast. Das sind dann eben ganz entscheidende Dinge, die in der Rolle spielen im Moment. Und du hast natürlich auch noch Champions League vor dir. Ich sage, Manchester City hat halt noch ein paar Spiele mehr auszutragen als Liverpool. Liga-Pokalfinale, FA kann jetzt eine Runde weiter. Champions League vermeintlich werden sie es überstehen gegen Schalke 04, wenn man sich die jeweiligen Formkurven anschaut, wenn man sich die Qualität anschaut innerhalb eines Kaders. Aber Manchester City wird dann auch noch in der Liga ein paar schwierige Spiele bekommen. Im Gegensatz dazu Liverpool, die eben dann im FA-Kampf nicht mal mit dabei sind. Es ist echt schwierig, wirklich eine Prognose abzugeben.
Ja, das musst du jetzt an der Stelle auch noch nicht tun. Ich habe noch einen Gedanken dazu, da würde mich deine Meinung interessieren. Kann es sein, wir alle fokussieren uns sehr gerne auf den Liverpooler Angriff und auch bei City guckt man gerne auf Aguero. Ich meine, allein gegen Arsenal hat er alle drei Treffer gemacht, auf Silva, auf Stirling. Aber könnte es vielleicht sein, dass der entscheidendere Faktor tatsächlich dem alten Sprichwort Defense wins championships die Abwehrreihen sind. Denn wenn ich mir angucke, in der wackeligen Phase von Manchester City war es so, dass sie Tore zugelassen haben, wie man es nicht erlebt hat. Und dann hatten sie trotz aller Spielanteile, die City immer hat, haben sie es irgendwie nicht mehr geschafft, das noch zu drehen. Und bei Liverpool war es ja jetzt ähnlich, dass man eigentlich unnötige Gegentore zugelassen hat und dann eben vorne nicht mehr als eins geschossen hat.
Ja, ja natürlich. Also ganz bestimmt sogar. Das ist zwar so ein bisschen abgedroschen, aber es steckt halt so viel Wahrheit dahinter. Und wir reden über zwei Abwehrreihen. Man City 20 Gegentore, Liverpool 15, das ist ja immer noch aller Ehren wert nach 25 oder 26 Spieltagen, was City hier an den Spielen mehr ausgetragen hat. Bei Liverpool ist es ganz wichtig, dass du merkst, dass ein Joe Gomez, der fehlt dann halt schon, auch an der Anloverin mit seiner Routine, mit seiner Erfahrung, auch mit seiner, wie soll ich das sagen, mit seiner positiven Aggressivität. Joel Martip hat eben noch Schwierigkeiten. Ich finde ihn eben noch nicht so gut, wie er vielleicht auch schon mal gespielt hat, liegt auch daran, weil er auch verletzt war. Dann das Fehlen von Sven-Alexander Arnold, also die eigentlich eingespielte Defensive davor mit einem unglaublich wichtigen Wijnaldum zumeist, da fehlte zuletzt so ein bisschen Balance. Und da hat Manchester City mit ihren Möglichkeiten im Moment, mit einer gewissen Eingespieltheit, aber auch mit einer gewissen Abgeklärtheit im Moment – wir reden ja immer nur über diese so vielzitierte Momentaufnahme – vielleicht gerade so einen kleinen Vorteil. Das kann sich natürlich aber ganz schnell wieder drehen. Das sind genau solche Feinheiten und Faktoren, die auch wichtig sind, wie stabil sind gerade die Spieler bzw. welche Verletzungsproblematiken hast du im Moment. Aber darauf wird es auf jeden Fall ankommen, weil wenn du halt zwei kassierst oder auch wenn du nur eins kassierst, musst halt dann schon mal zwei oder drei Tore schießen. Und wenn das dann mal nicht funktioniert, dann wirst du ein Problem haben. Also die Defensive wird sicherlich ganz entscheidend sein, aber ich rede das nicht nur über die Abwehrkette, sondern das fängt ja überall dann letztendlich schon an. Und dann musst du schon griffig sein und musst eine richtig gute Balance haben im Team. Und Tottenham zum Beispiel hat es jetzt vorgemacht, zuletzt auch ohne einen Harry Kane oder ohne einen Daley Alley. Das waren knappe Resultate. Haben wir jetzt nicht den Gegner schön gespielt und fünf, sechs Stück reingehauen, sondern die Spiele knapp gewonnen. 1-0, 1-0, 2-1, noch ein Spiel gedreht. Das ist ja ganz wichtig. Aber das zeigt halt, wie wichtig es ist, vielleicht dann auch erst mal zu sagen, wir werden unsere Chancen kriegen, aber wir dürfen bloß nicht irgendwie uns zu viele Gegendore fangen.
Jetzt hast du mit Tottenham auch schon das dritte Team genannt. Was du laut unserem Vorgespräch, was wir geführt haben, schon irgendwie noch mit reinrechnest in die Tabellenspitze, was ich interessant finde, weil die fallen in der Betrachtung von vielen anderen meistens raus. Fünf Punkte Rückstand haben die Spurs auf Liverpool und City, haben schon sechs Niederlagen, aber dafür eben kein einziges Unentschieden. Was macht denn Tottenham richtig, dass du glaubst, die könnten vielleicht, gerade auch weil sie unter dem Radar ein bisschen fliegen, da nochmal eingreifen?
Es ist ja schon mal verrückt, dass sie noch nie Unentschieden gespielt haben mit dieser Saison. Das ist echt sehr bemerkenswert. Ich glaube, dass sie – vielleicht finde ich es sogar ganz gut, dass sie gar nicht so eingerechnet werden ins Titelrennen, wobei ja schon immer mehr Stimmen da kommen, die natürlich auch die Spurs nicht aus den Augen verloren haben. Die Spurs spielen, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, A noch gegen Liverpool. Sie spielen auch noch gegen Manchester City in dieser Saison. Vielleicht ist das so nach dem Motto, naja, die Verletzungen, die sie auch jetzt kassiert haben. Ich habe ja mit Harry Kane schon angefangen und Elie Elie. Vielleicht ist das Team dann noch enger zusammengerückt und spielen vielleicht dann noch mehr als kollektiv. Das kann eine ganz, ganz positive Aura auch ausstrahlen und auch dir geben innerhalb der Mannschaft, also innerhalb auch der Kabine, dass die Verantwortung doch viel, vielen Schultern natürlich auch gelegt ist. Weil sie wissen, wir haben jetzt zwei ganz wichtige Spieler nicht dabei, mal gucken, wann sie wieder kommen und wann sie dann möglicherweise auch erst wieder ihre Form wieder erlangen. Das ist ja auch immer die andere Seite der Medaille. Nach längerer Ausfallzeit brauchst du vielleicht auch noch mal zwei, drei, vier Wochen, bis du wieder deinen Optimum erreicht hast. Das macht sie so ein bisschen unberechenbarer, finde ich. Und jeder, der da jetzt spielt, kann und weiß, dass er Verantwortung trägt und weiß, dass er sehr, sehr wichtig ist für die Mannschaft. Und das demonstrieren sie gerade. Und ich halte sie nach wie vor da im Titlerennen, weil es sind nur fünf Punkte. Und wir haben mit davon geredet, dass Liverpool die Chance hat, auf sieben davon zu ziehen. Und das haben sie halt nicht geschafft. So, und wenn sie ihre Spiele so gewinnen, wie sie sie jetzt gewonnen haben, dann sind sie halt weiterhin drin. So, und vielleicht kommen sie da aus dem Windschatten noch heraus. Und überholen auch die beiden, wer weiß. Also das kann passieren. Ich möchte sie halt eben noch nicht irgendwie aus dem Titlerennen raus. Dafür sind halt eben noch zu viele Spiele zu absolvieren.
Das definitiv. Werden beides Auswärtspartien sein? Also sowohl in Liverpool Ende März als auch dann in Manchester, bei City Ende April. Vielleicht werden sie ja dann auch Zünglern an der Waage. Überhaupt haben die Spurs jetzt einen sehr, sehr interessanten Schedule, wenn man sich die nächsten Spiele noch anguckt, gegen Leicester, dann natürlich gegen Dortmund in Burnley und dann Chelsea Arsenal als nächste beiden Partien und dann das Rückspiel gegen Dortmund. Also da stehen jetzt tatsächlich interessante Wochen an für die Spurs. Die Stadionfrage knick ich mir an der Stelle mal. Ja, wirklich, NFL denn? Nein. Nein, das lassen wir mal lieber stecken, sondern beschäftigen uns kurz mal mit Chelsea. Was gibt es denn zu denen zu sagen? Das sind jetzt schon 12 Punkte Rückstand auf die ersten beiden Tabellenplätze, die jetzt vielleicht aber auch schon länger ein bisschen aus dem Fokus geraten sind. Von hinten schieben aber Manchester United und Arsenal schon ein bisschen an. Wie siehst du denn die Situation in London bei Chelsea? Die haben ja zweimal verloren in den letzten drei Liga-Spielen.
Absolut, ja. Gut, Gonzalo Vigo bei ihnen funktioniert er relativ ordentlich, muss man sagen. Den Stürmer, den Maurizio Sarri unbedingt wollte. Ja, bei Chelsea – sie sind echt gut angefangen unter Sarri. Und man hat auch gesehen, was auch mit der Mannschaft vorhat. Chelsea spürt natürlich jetzt auch diesen Druck von Manchester United dahinter. Und Arsenal ist auch nicht weit weg. Die müssen halt auch permanent liefern. Bei Chelsea tue ich mich aber so ein bisschen schwer, weil das so durchzuhalten mit der Mannschaft, mit der Sarri ja permanent spielt. Also es gibt ja kaum Veränderungen. Ich habe Chelsea jetzt am Wochenende bei Manchester City und ich habe mir da auch schon so ein paar Dinge natürlich angeguckt. Also Rotation ist ja bei Sarri eigentlich ein Fremdwort. Das muss man ja ganz klar sagen. Er kann so von hinten anfangen, vom Torwart bis nach vorne. Nehmen wir mal Egoin raus. Aber der wird jetzt auch noch auf schöne Zahlen kommen dann bis zum Saisonende, wenn er sich dann nicht verletzt. Und ob sie das dann so durchhalten, da bin ich jetzt sehr, sehr gespannt darauf. Da ist mir, sagen wir mal, die Breite des Kaders, die ist zwar ordentlich, aber die wird halt nicht so wenig genutzt. Und ob sie damit so umgehen können bis zum Ende der Saison, das wird sicherlich spannend sein. Klar, sie haben eine Titelchance, Liga-Pokalfinale. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Abramowitsch, als er dies so reicht. Ich weiß nicht, was mit Eden Hazard auch so passiert. Da kann es natürlich auch mal schnell noch sein, dass da ein bisschen Unruhe kommt. Verlängert er jetzt endlich? Oder was passiert da eigentlich? Was sagen denn die Spieler, die jetzt immer noch zum meisten auf der Bank sitzen? Bleibt Olivier Giroud tatsächlich auch ruhig? Wer hat da wieder einen vor der Nase? Und, und, und. Hat es nur Deuthema und so weiter. Also, schaffen sie es tatsächlich so, konstant an durchzukommen? Mir ist das zu schwankend. Also bei Chelsea kann immer so viel passieren. Sie spielen echt einen guten Stiefel mal und dann verlieren sie plötzlich einen Bournemouth mit 4-0. Das war völlig überraschend und fast aus der Luft gegriffen im Grunde genommen. Also da, ja, da kann die Gefahr ganz schnell auch aufkommen, dass man sich möglicherweise am Saisonende nicht in den Champions-League-Ring wiederfindet. Weil da ist es einfach noch so ein bisschen zu, ja, zu unausgegorn, was da so wirklich passiert. Und man weiß ja auch, Abramovic ist jetzt nicht so der Geduldigste und fordert sehr, sehr viel ein. Und bekommt Serie dann auch tatsächlich diese Möglichkeit, diese Mannschaft weiterzuentwickeln. Das ist sicherlich auch ein Punkt, den man nicht außer Acht lassen kann.
Ja, und diese Belastung, das ist halt wirklich ein Faktor. Also es gibt acht Spieler im Team, die entweder 24 oder 25, also alle Ligaspiele bisher gemacht haben. Und das ist für die Premier League so untypisch. Ich meine, wir kennen das, in Napoli hat das ja ähnlich gehalten. Aber in Napoli hat man zum Beispiel auch in der letzten Saison gesehen, in den entscheidenden Phasen dann. Wir erinnern uns an dieses Auswärtsspiel bei Juve, war es glaube ich im April, da hat es dann eben nicht mehr gereicht. Und da konnte man dann von der Bank aus nicht mehr nachlegen, während die Gegner immer mehr wieder geschafft haben. Das könnte echt ein Faktor sein.
Ja, und die Leute, die von der Bank kommen, die brauchen auch ein bisschen Spielpraxis, Spielrhythmus, aber den bekommst du halt nicht, wenn du halt mal hier 10 Minuten und da 8 Minuten spielst, das reicht halt nicht. Und sie spielen auch FA-Cup, ja, aber da hast du Manchester United dann vor der Brust. Und dann haben sie glaube ich noch von den großen Liverpool auf jeden Fall hinten raus. Das geht auch so Richtung April, Manchester United, Ende des Monats Tottenham. Also ob sie das dann tatsächlich durchhalten, wir sprachen ja schon über Frische bei den ganz oben, die da stehen, und da ist es echt sehr, das ist fast gar nicht durchzuhalten auf diesem Niveau. Dort wirklich 38 Spieltage plus dann Europa League. Kann ja auch nochmal sehr interessant werden, wie weit soll es da kommen. Das kann ja dann auch so eine kleine Fußnote sein im Hinblick auf, wenn wir es vielleicht in die Champions nicht über die Liga schaffen, vielleicht können wir die Europa League gewinnen, da werden sie es sicherlich auch nicht abschenken. Das ist schon hochinteressant bei denen.
Und es kommt eben einfach noch der Faktor Manchester United mit rein, die jetzt aus den letzten 6 Ligaspielen 16 von 18 möglichen Punkten geholt haben. Was zur Hölle ist denn mit United passiert?
Ja, das ist hochinteressant immer. Wenn dann plötzlich einer da draußen steht, der die Spieler anders anpackt und plötzlich ihnen da ein Lächeln wieder ins Gesicht zaubert und ihnen Dinge mit an die Hand gibt. Wir wissen ja nicht, welche Dinge er da tatsächlich gesteuert hat.
Genau, das wäre meine Frage gewesen. Es kann ja nicht nur das Lächeln im Gesicht gewesen sein.
Genau, Babyface Assassin kann es immer nicht nur sein. Ich glaube, das ist einfach – im Nachhinein sind wir immer schlauer zu sagen, Herr Jose Mourinho musste weg. Es ist ja nicht nur die Personalie Ole Gunnar Solskjaer. Ich glaube, dass Mike Fielen da eine ganz große Rolle spielt, der auch den Club kennt, der übrigens auch gekannt wird von Spielern. Er war da ein paar Jahre mit Sir Dix Ferguson, auch noch an der Seitenlinie war. Du hast Michael Carrick da, der den Verein ja auch wirklich bestens kennt. Wir sind bei den Trainingseinheiten nie dabei. Wir sind bei den Mannschaftsbesprechungen auch nie dabei. Es ist halt immer nur das, was man auch in der Öffentlichkeit liest. Und Ole Gunnar Solskjaer vertritt diesen Verein herausragend, präsentiert diesen Verein herausragend und präsentiert auch seine Mannschaft herausragend. Also wenn man ihn auch in Interviews erlebt, sehr offen, sehr sympathisch. Da wird kein Spieler irgendwie an die Wand genagelt. Er sieht das große Ganze. Er sieht einfach diesen Club und ergibt diesen Spielern so, scheint es jedenfalls. Das Vertrauen, was sie möglicherweise eben, oder vereinzelte, nicht von Jose Mourinho bekommen haben. Also ich glaube, dass es auch wichtig ist, wichtig war, die ersten Spiele da erfolgreich bestritten zu haben. Was wäre denn passiert, wenn der Aufleiter die ersten zwei verloren hätte? Schaffst du es dann trotzdem, die ganze Atmosphäre auf links zu drehen? Oder hätten das die Spieler geschafft? Das weiß man ja auch im Nachhinein logischerweise nicht. Jetzt ist es positiv gelaufen. Ich weiß nicht, was er macht, aber vielleicht ist es eben genau dieses Händchen oder vielleicht ist es die Motivation, die er da reinbringt. Mike Vihl natürlich immer mit an Bord geholt, der dann auch in den Trainingssessions dort richtige und wichtige Impulse gesteuert hat. Das kann natürlich alles sein. Jedenfalls ist es so, dass die Spieler scheinbar eine ganz große Last verloren haben. Und jetzt glaube ich, wie ich finde, mehr Freiheiten ausstrahlen auf dem Platz.
An wem kann man das festmachen? Gibt es da Leute, die besonders hervortreten? Also Paul Pogba ist natürlich der bekannteste Name.
Auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, er war in den vergangenen 8 Spielen an 11 Toren beteiligt. Das sah ja schon eine Menge aus. Da hätte ich ja beinahe gesagt, das sind ja ungefähr so viele wie in seiner bisherigen Zeit bei Manchester United. Marcus Rashford, der war auch schon unter Jose Mourinho kein schlechter. Aber keiner moppert mehr auf. Er hat auch Alexis Sanchez wieder ein bisschen mehr Vertrauen eingeimpft und hat ihm positiv geredet. Das sind genau diese Stärken, die ich meinte, in der Öffentlichkeit. Ein Phil Jones verlängert jetzt seinen Vertrag. Ein Ander Herrera schwärmt auch in der Öffentlichkeit, bekommt plötzlich auch mehr Spielminuten. Da gibt es mehrere Beispiele, die man netten könnte. Das hat viel bewirkt bei Manchester United. Mit so einem Run bist du plötzlich mitten drin, um die Champions-League-Plätze zu kämpfen. Das wäre natürlich nach all den Negativerlebnissen in dieser Saison. Mit so weitem Abstand, den man zwischendurch hatte, wäre das ein Monster-Erfolg, wenn United da noch auf Platz 4 einlaufen würde. Das muss man mal ganz klar so sagen. Aber scheinbar hat Ole Gunnar Solskjaer, Mike Phelan, Michael Carrick irgendetwas gemacht, das die Mannschaft so wiederbelebt hat. Aber nochmal, wir bewerten das immer nur von außen, können aber nicht entscheidend immer sagen, was dann da so passiert ist. Manchmal nehmen solche Dinge eine Eigendynamik an, die auch ins letzte Detail nicht immer wirklich erklärbar ist.
Der Typhoon-Corkut-Effekt nennt man das. Also zwei Punkte Rückstand sind es für United auf Chelsea aktuell, die eben auf dem Vierten und da mit dem Champions League Platz liegen. Und hinter United, mit einem Pünktchen Abstand, läuft aktuell der FC Arsenal ein, dann erfolgt ein kleiner Cut. Das sind wie immer die Big Six in der Premier League. Wie ist denn da deine Einschätzung zur Lage bei Arsenal?
Das muss man ganz klar sagen. Bedingt auch dadurch, weil sie ja wirklich Verletzungspech haben. Das darf man auch nicht außer Acht lassen. Bestes Beispiel ist natürlich Hector Bayerín, gerade so langsam wieder fit geworden. Und dann diese schwere Knieverletzung. Dann kommt Sokrates dazu. Koschelny war lange verletzt. Es ist eben merkenswert, dass der wieder so eine vernünftige Form hat nach seiner Achilles-Szene-Geschichte. Dazu natürlich die Sager um Mesut Özil. Mal drin, mal längere Zeit nicht drin. Du hast dann vorne auch mit Lacazette Aubameyang zwei, von denen du auch abhängig bist. Aber das ist alles noch zu unkonstant, auch wenn sie zwischendurch mal 22 Spiele in Folge umgeschlagen gewesen sind. Aber sie haben sich ja auch nicht den übigen Vorsprung vor der Konkurrenz erarbeitet. Das muss man ja auch mal ganz klar sagen, weil es dann immer noch andere Mannschaften gab, die auch fleißig gepunktet haben. Und es waren ja auch ein paar Unentschieden mit dabei. Das ist unkonstant auf der einen Seite, trotzdem sage ich auch. Ich hätte es übrigens von unkonstant, von den Ergebnissen her, auch von der Leistung her, du hast mal den Eindruck, so jetzt funktioniert es. Zweite Hälfte Tottenham, Heimspiel gegen Chelsea, zum Beispiel zuletzt gegen Manchester City war so ein Rückfall in ganz komische Zeiten, wo es von der Einstellung her auch nicht so wirklich passte. Das ist genau auch diese Unkonstanz, die ich meine. Und da muss man einem Una Emery, der so große Fußstapfen zu bewältigen, hat einfach auch diese Zeit geben. Er hat jetzt ein kleines Transferfenster mal gehabt und er wird auch seine Mannschaft dahin formen, dass sie dann möglicherweise in der kommenden Saison noch konstanter sich zeigen kann, als sie es mal zwischendurch getan hat. Das wird ganz, ganz schwierig dort Platz 4 zu erreichen, weil sie eben nicht diese Beständigkeit haben und weil sie zu wankelmütig sind. Das wird noch ein bisschen Zeit in Anspruch nehmen.
So ein bisschen Arsene, wie immer nur unter geänderten Vorzeichen. Also manche Konstanten haben sich dann nicht so ganz verändert in der Premier League und mit dem kleinen Transferfensterchen hast du vermutlich auf Denis Suárez angespielt, den man von Barca geliehen hat fürs zentrale Mittelfeld.
Ja, aber es reicht halt nicht. In der Abwehr musst du halt dringend was machen, um da auch Tempo wieder reinzubekommen. Bei allem Respekt vor Laurent Koschelny, vor Sokratis, vor Skodra Mustafi. Aber da fehlt es gerade im Zentrum. Rob Holding fehlt natürlich auch. Schmerzlich, gar keine Frage. Aber da brauchst du einen wirklichen, modernen Innenverteidiger, der auch dann Tempo mitbringt. Das wird sicherlich auch eine Baustelle sein, die man sich im Sommer ganz genau anguckt. Und dann bin ich sehr gespannt, wen sie da holen. Aber sie sind da auch noch in der Europa League mit dabei. Werden wahrscheinlich nicht so die ganz großen Argumente haben, es sei denn, sie gewinnen die Europa League und sind dann in der Königsliste vertreten, einen herausragenden Innenverteidiger zu holen, weil ich glaube, dass herausragende Innenverteidiger, vor allen Dingen andere Traktivte, auch immer gesucht werden. Dementsprechend, es geht wirklich um Konstanz da reinzubringen. Und es dauert ja auch eine Zeit. Ich habe das auch schon so häufig gesagt in Kommentaren. Es hat seine Zeit gedauert bei Man City mit Pep Guardiola. Wir müssen uns mal alle erinnern, wo sind die eigentlich gewesen in der ersten Saison. Wir waren nämlich titellos unter Pep. Unter Jürgen Klopp hat das gedauert. Maurizio Pogetino entwickelt seit 4, 5 Jahren Tottenham weiter. Es braucht einfach Zeit. So One-Hit-Wonder kann es mal geben, wie Claudio Ranieri und Leicester oder Antonio Conte und Chelsea. Aber um wirklich was aufzubauen, ich weiß, es klingt doof, braucht es aber eben etwas. Manchmal hat man eben die Zeit nicht im Fußball. Aber ich glaube, dass es bei Arsenal so ist, dass man genau weiß, dass man ohne MRE auch jetzt nicht nach dieser ersten Saison gleich so bewerten muss, wie vielleicht dann eben nach 3 oder nach 4 Jahren.
So wirkt es zumindest aktuell. Gibt es denn jetzt noch ein Team, auf das du gerne noch eingehen wollen würdest? Also wir haben jetzt mal wieder die üblich Verdächtigen abgehandelt, weil sich da aber auch ein bisschen was getan hat. Aber wer hat dir da vielleicht noch gefehlt jetzt?
Och du, in der Summe eigentlich. Gut, oben können wir über keinen anderen mehr sprechen letztendlich. Aber es kann immer natürlich passieren, und das ist ja eben auch das alles Entscheidende. Wir haben das ja jetzt gesehen mit Newcastle zum Beispiel gegen Manchester City. Wir haben das gesehen bei West Ham. Übrigens auch von Mannschaften wie West Ham, die mit keiner guten Form im Grunde genommen in das Spiel gegangen sind gegen Liverpool, die sich plötzlich zerrissen haben und sich dadurch auch belohnt haben. Auch völlig zurecht damit mit dem Punkt. Mannschaften, die gerade sich so im Mittelfeld tummeln, die mit oben nichts zu tun haben, auch nicht mit Europa League, die auch mit unten nichts zu tun haben, die können vielleicht dem einen oder anderen da oben noch einen Punkt klauen. Und dann sind es ganz, ganz wichtige Punkte, die sie da klauen. Ob das jetzt Bournemouth ist, spielen jetzt in Liverpool, wird schwierig genug, aber plötzlich schlagen die Chelsea, wir haben darüber gesprochen. Da fehlen glaube ich jetzt auch zwei mit Callum Wilson und Brooks, glaube ich, die auch nicht so schlecht performt haben in dieser Saison bei Bournemouth. Leicester hat einen guten Kader, kann immer mal auch da Spiele gewinnen. Siehe Manchester City, Everton, also diese Mannschaften, die auch mit unten gar nichts mehr zu tun haben werden. Das ist halt spannend. Können die tatsächlich dem einen oder anderen da oben in irgendetwas reinspucken, von denen, die da oben dann meinen, oh, oh, jetzt müssen wir wieder aufpassen. Das finde ich halt echt an dieser Liga so faszinierend.
Burnley, die letzten sechs Spiele in der Liga nicht verloren, drei Siege, drei Unentschieden, Southampton von den letzten sechs Spielen. Genau. Zwei Siege, drei Unentschieden, eine Niederlage. Und trotzdem sind beide nur, also hängen immer noch unten drin mit zwei Punkten Vorsprung vor Cardiff. Und dann Fulham hat das viel schon ganz schön abgeschlagen. Eigentlich ja erstaunlich, dass sie da unten so eine Serie starten, aber nicht vom Fleck kommen.
Da gibt es noch einige andere Mannschaften. Wenn wir über die Spurs reden, die nur 5 Punkte Rückstand haben, dann kann man sagen, Brighton hat auch nur 5 Punkte Vorsprung auf Cardiff. Crystal Palace, Newcastle, Southampton, Burnley, Cardiff, das werden die Mannschaften sein, die diesen letzten, vermeintlich letzten Abstiegsplatz unter sich ausmachen. Sie kämpfen gegen sich selbst. Sie werden jedes Wochenende schön spüren, was es bedeutet, Abschließkampf zu haben. Gerade so direkte Duelle werden ganz entscheidend sein. Und gegen die vermeintlichen Favoriten bist du Underdog. Und dann hast du die Möglichkeit, okay, das könnte ein Bonuspunkt für uns sein. Oder vielleicht im Optimalfall wie bei Newcastle, vielleicht können wir sogar mal drei holen. Das ist schon erstaunlich. Du siehst halt, wie eng das ist. Und auch mit einem Sieg bist du jetzt nicht davon, oder bist du weit davon entfernt, zu sagen, ich verabschiede mich jetzt mal aus der Abstiegszone. Aber du siehst, jetzt wird es langsam knackig. Und jetzt darfst du dir auch nicht mehr so viele Fehler erlauben. Ich glaube, dass die direkten Duellen sicherlich mitentscheidend sind. Und gegen die Mittelfeld-Teams müssen gerade die dir unten am besten nicht verlieren. Das ist das alles entscheidend, also leicht gesagt schwer getan. Also ich glaube auch, dass Fulham und Halas fehlt. Also Halas fehlt sowieso.
Also auch der aktuelle Club von Andre Schürrle. Das wäre dann meine nächste Frage gewesen. Tatsächlich glaube ich, Burnley – vielleicht bin ich da auch geprägt von diesen sechs sehr, sehr guten Spieltagen, die man da in der Liga hatte. Aber wer weiß, ob die vielleicht hinten raus auch nochmal in die Big Six eingreifen. Weil wenn die letzten vier Spiele von denen sind in London bei Chelsea, dann zu Hause gegen City, dann bei Everton – das würde ich jetzt mal rausstreichen – und dann zu Hause gegen Arsenal. Also, interessantes Schlussprogramm. Wer weiß, ob es für Arsenal dann noch um was geht. Da könnte tatsächlich dann das passieren, was du gesagt hast, dass die da unten dann oben eingreifen irgendwie. Und die Mittelklasse-Teams, die hast du ja auch alle genannt, haben wir ja mit Bournemouth unter anderem gesehen gegen Chelsea.
Da ist ja immer alles möglich. Da geht es wirklich auf dieses entscheidende Ziel gerade. Du weißt, du hast im Kopf, wir haben jetzt nicht noch 15 Spiele vor uns und vielleicht noch die vierte oder fünfte FA-Cup-Runde oder so. Da ist halt schon sehr viel in eine gewisse Richtung gesteuert, auch bei den Top-Vereinen. Die wissen dann, sind wir noch Champions League oder sind wir noch in der Europa League mit dabei. In diesen Spielen geht es da meistens echt immer hoch her. Und du weißt, heute zählst und wir haben noch drei Spieltage und da ist so viel möglich, weil die Zeit dann, irgendetwas zu reparieren, die hast du halt eben nicht mehr. Und dann, genau, da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht. Und dann musst du auch gegen Burnley erst mal bestehen. Das wird sehr, sehr spannend, weil es dann echt um alles geht.
Und mit City haben sie noch eine Rechnung offen. Aber das führt jetzt so weit. Dann gab es noch die gute Nachricht zum Abschluss der Sendung. Die Premier League-Vereine haben sich darauf verständigt, dass die Kappung der Auswärtsticketspreise bei 30 Pfund jetzt für drei Saisons verlängert wurde. Also da haben die englischen Fans eine ähnliche Aktion gefahren, wie eins die Deutschen mit kein 25. Stär. Und das wurde jetzt um drei Spielzeiten verlängert. 30 Pfund immer noch ein ordentliches Wort. Aber schön zu sehen, dass es wenigstens an der Stelle dann mal ein Limit gibt für das, was man so einnehmen muss.
Absolut.
Und mit dieser guten Nachricht, würde ich sagen, können wir doch alle Hörerinnen und Hörer ins verdiente Wochenende entlassen. Und auch dich, Marco. Marco, danke dir, dass du mal mitgemacht hast im Rasenfunk. Man kann dir auf Twitter folgen, atmarco-hagemann und auch in allen anderen sozialen Netzwerken. Bist du aktiv? So wie der Rasenfunk natürlich auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Verfolgt uns überall. Und wenn ihr es noch nicht gehört habt, dann hört doch mal das Tribüngespräch mit Thomas Breuch, was an diesem Mittwoch erschienen ist. Also fast offen frisch noch serviert wird. Und die nächste Schlusskonferenz zur Bundesliga gibt es dann am Montagnachmittag. Bis dahin wünsche ich euch ein wunderbares Sportwochenende und bis zum nächsten Mal in einem der Formate des Rasenfunks. Ciao!